I'm in full anticipation right now cuz
we haven't seen it there's a lot of
stuff that we don't know there's a lot
of stuff that we do know I know that but
to be able to play in almost a theater
you know platform with my buddy so I've
known for a long time some of I done it
some of them I don't know if some of my
god - now some I've worked with some
unknown for years was more than a blast
and I would love to keep doing it again
and again and again and you go into
comic book stores and you start asking
questions and all that and there's it's
like PhDs in comic book characters and
Marvel characters and it's kind of
fascinating I mean these people like
lived this stuff and I was a comic book
guy but not as much as some of the
people that I've met so you really do
when you're doing it you feel like not
only you're doing it as a job or for the
studio you feel like you're doing it for
the fans and I've never experienced that
before that's pretty great it's so crazy
it's so crazy man and and even for like
Robert Downey jr. this is crazy that's
how crazy this is you talk to him and I
was really Merlin like how are you
feeling man he's like dude this is
insane and when Robert Downey jr. says
something's insane it's definitely gonna
be a crazy day so it's really awesome
and everyone here is amazing and it's
just it's blowing my mind I mean for me
Wow I mean where do I begin you know I
mean to just even be in this universe
alone and then to play spider-man is
another level to add on top of it and to
be 21 like it just it blows my mind
every day and I can't believe that it's
genuinely happening and I'm so grateful
to Marvel and Sony for taking the risk
and giving me the job and it's amazing
I just want to see it so bad I just want
to see it so bad I want to get in there
see the film and it's gonna I just I
can't wait I'm so excited I just I just
can't wait yes well that so it's a
weirdly exciting event in the sense that
we're all a bit nervous about our
contribution as actors generally are but
at the same time I can speak for myself
when I say this you know you're a small
little tiny square and a massive mosaic
so you could there's a lot of other
people's brilliant work to enjoy so I'm
really excited to see it yeah amazing
soul in Singapore were just
extraordinary the airport at Seoul was
just unbelievable I mean people have
been there for a long time and they went
crazy and Tom got there I think in the
morning we got there sort of
mid-afternoon and it was just this
frenzy and then Tom Holland and I
arrived together and it was crazy but
they were so respectful and lovely and
devoted and just you know mobile friends
are the best and when you see that
around the world you know it's a very
it's a good family to be part of and
Singapore was a fantastic event and we
had live link ups with the Philippines
and here it's been crazy as you can
imagine and just yeah that's what it's
all about
it's for the fans we experimented we
were always passing up the script I was
working with two well one in particular
master improviser in rock our DJ and
Robert and and also Tom Holland who was
just riding that wave of success for
Spidey and he came on the set and just
was so bang on you know
that was inspiring and the Russos were
like normal directors in front of a
couple of cameras literally quite big
set but nothing daunted them and you had
a normal day's work it normalized I
think is what I'm trying to say
I know it's actually gonna be really fun
because you know I feel like this is how
it's technically supposed to be you're
going to the premiere you're gonna see
the finished product you don't know what
you're gonna see and so it's it's for me
it's like just everything is the icing
on the cake at this point you know I
think you have to factor in the you know
ten years of Marvel movies that you've
had 19 films at this point so it's it's
it's the fact that the fans and sort of
globally everybody's been prepared for
this one way or another and that you
know we're all invested in the
characters and you know them and and
it's kind of you care for them so that
has a lot going for it when you go into
this film you know and and that's Marvel
just being genius of what they do and
being able to craft everything every
film up to this point so you're you're
gonna get that final final hit but no
pun intended or anything but I come from
theater and so for me the the watching
the audience and having that feedback
right after a performance was something
really special we don't get to do that
often with films except for in a
situation like this so here you are you
get to be with people and you get to see
their reactions firsthand and kind of
it's it's a very special feeling ten
years ago never could have imagined the
scope of this it's so enormous and you
know I think it's just to be able to
stand kind of you know side by side with
my fellow Avengers and and feel like I
have you know I felt pretty kind of
grounded I you know in this experience
I've been fortunate enough to play this
character you know for a long time and
you know be able to really celebrate her
her journey and and take it with her and
and it feels good I don't know how they
did it but I'm excited to see him they
didn't you know it's been I
I really I think everybody has kind of
their moment and like the Russos really
have somehow magically honored like
everyone's like all these separate
franchises in one single film it's kind
of crazy how they did it I don't know I
mean to deal with the double or
something totally it's always you know
I'm when I first came on to play Black
Widow and Iron Man 2 I was so nervous
that the fans would even yeah I know how
they would embrace this character my
portrayal of this character I mean the
Black Widow is a character that's only
all of the characters in this in this
universe are so meaningful for people so
the fact that you know the fans have
come along on this whole journey with me
is very touching and I feel like you
know if ever someone comes up to me and
is a fan of the character and tells me
they like my portrayal of her you know I
feel like I've done my job you know it's
exciting it's such a testament to the
story making that brings us together as
humanity instead of tearing us apart
these are good stories you know so yeah
it's it's pretty amazing to go all over
the world and and see the same
enthusiasm and love and and support you
know it's pretty amazing to be here yeah
we've got you know everywhere you look
you see a star from the Marvel Universe
it's been 10 years in the making this
film coming together it's truly an
unprecedented cinematic event and yeah I
know we're all thrilled to be here yeah
these these films really do exist
because of the fans I mean there's no
way you could ever tell a more there's
no way you could ever make a movie like
this and have it make any sense if you
didn't have a baked in fandom you know
we've have a teen films leading up to
this movie and the crazy thing is is the
in the entire world have seen all 18 of
those films what else
unifies the entire world in that way I
mean like no matter where you go no
matter what country you go to there are
people who know these characters and and
it's it's so imperative to understand
the the plights of each of these
characters and the desires of these
characters that inner workings of each
of these characters when you watch a
movie like this because you can't sit
there and explain
to an audience who all these people are
you you kind of need to know going in
and for the most part the world knows
and so it's amazing it's a testament to
the fans and everywhere we go there are
people really excited about this outside
right now there's thousands of people
lined up they've been camping for out
four days and you know they're really
passionate and we all just see it as a
huge responsibility to deliver films
that live up to the legacy that that
we're all honored to be part of created
by Stan Lee and now taken taken on over
by Disney in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we're just thrilled to be here
yeah really is the world premiere it's
nice you know most the time you do a
movie and you go to the premiere and and
it's really a gift you give to your
audience members and you say here's a
movie we worked on you go ahead and
watch it
we really get to enjoy this gift and
unwrap this gift and see what's inside
it as well because it's such a massive
film on people only ever were given this
the the scenes that they were in and
know they're very few characters who
were in you know the majority of the
whole movie and so I'm excited to get in
there and see what happened it's pretty
exciting because besides being a part of
these films you know I'm also a fan and
I'm I'm a huge fan as you guys can tell
of science fiction and of action driven
movies and and I am a kid at heart so
getting to live you know everyday
fictitional characters that inspired me
and knowing you know the importance of
the positive messages to a younger
audience just makes me feel lucky to go
to work and say that I I play Gamora and
the Marvel Universe every day I can't
wait I cannot wait is the first time my
life that I've I've done press and I've
gotten this far without seeing the film
that I'm in so I've been I've been a
nervous wreck all weekend but I've also
been super excited like any fan to see
it Kevin foggy and his team and look
everybody all the riders all the crew
well there
actors directors everybody who was
involved in these films in this
experience everybody wrote the comic
books for the previous 5060 years it's
all kind of led to to this moment for a
lot of us in and to be a part of it in
any shape or form is a blessing I gotta
say this a real nostalgic kind of vibe
going on I feel and emotional more than
any other film or premiere I've been to
because you know this could possibly be
the last time we ever do this and I mean
who knows or it may not be does it does
this is often you've seen it three or
four times you know like writing you
pretending they'll be real reactions in
there good or bad who knows hopefully
good I'm gonna film it though and just
broadcast it to people who couldn't make
it tonight kidding kidding kidding
kidding
anybody's got shot in the neck right now
and just drop that affront it's a high
possibility and coming five years up
there the slingshot amazing it is and
look there you have the die-hard fans of
the comics and then the die-hard fans of
the film films but we've kind of
branched outside both of those things
now and and and I think still satisfied
that the fan base but kept them guessing
and advancing and growing and learning
from each other and expanding and that
is thanks to you know the people behind
the scenes who do all the magic we just
show up and read the lines if we can yes
it is yeah well what's so interesting is
the first couple of times I played Loki
I was very much the antagonist first
time in Thor introducing him to the
world Thor's brother god of mischief
Avengers definitely the bad guy Thor the
dark world is he good is he bad thor
ragnarok kind of on his way back to the
gird Avengers infinity war question mark
you know the stakes are high and Thanos
is coming and low-key and Thanos have
history because Thanos was the one that
lent him the sceptre in the first
Avengers movie to take over the earth
and it didn't work
so it is extraordinary and it has been a
source of constant surprise to me that
that these movies are so warmly embraced
by so many people everywhere in the
world I have not found a pocket of the
planet where people don't know who Loki
is if you find one let me know
and it's amazing it's so gratifying
because actually the love you know
Marvel are so generous towards the fans
and that generosity has been
reciprocated and I we feel that when we
travel around the world and it's like we
in the cast feel like a family and we
also feel like the family has many
members in the audience and and it's an
extraordinary thing to be part of yeah
so I have no idea how they did that and
actually did it without give me anybody
the full script so and we're here we
even have nobody seen the movie I don't
know how to Russo brothers who lets them
who lets them get away with this
man it's really really exciting it's
something that's not been done in a long
time
and to be able to be here and this is
happening and be at the forefront with
everybody I'm really excited I'm really
excited to see the movie as well
a man seeing it now on the big screen
it's cool it's fun really happy and I'm
looking forward to seeing how this mumps
upon mumps of secrecy has now you know
been pieced together and come together
so really excited about it yes super
gratifying because we've not seen a
character like this in so long or not on
our movie screens and everybody is able
to really relate to her and and connect
with her and yeah it's just it's just an
amazing thing really positive so yeah
I'm really grateful really happy I'm so
excited
ya know you know it's a weird thing is
this nobody seen the film so we're like
all dying you know so it was just and so
weird the way we shot it was you know
throughout the years but it was a little
bits and pieces so we're trying to put
it together in our heads but none of us
could really have a grasp of it and so
ya know like everybody's dying to see in
the film I think you know the last
couple days we've done press junkets and
we're all walking into rooms you know
seeing each other for the first time in
a long time and the first thing we're
all saying is have you seen it never you
seen it have you seen it and then
probably know the first person says yeah
I'm gonna see we're all gonna be pissed
on okay it's just super jealous oh
you've seen it no none of us have seen
it I literally don't know how they did
it I'm so impressed with them this is
the biggest undertaking in Hollywood
history not only because what they've
done they've managed to take ten years
worth of storytelling and put it into
you know a couple films but logistically
they have gotten all these movie stars
from all these different projects all
over the world and they've scheduled
them to come in and work together
without attitudes well everybody ain't
being in a really good mood in a great
atmosphere like that is what an
undertaking man they are just uh there
are head and shoulders above the
restaurant it is amazing I mean it's
it's it's so great that we can bring all
these characters together and have these
worlds collide and come up with all
these different storylines that you know
independently you wouldn't you know work
but now we're all coming together to
fight this one
terrible bad guy and I can't wait I hope
it's good
haven't seen anything in my in it you
could tell me I mean it's it's amazing
that I think it's a testament to the
faithfulness to the brand and that you
know Marvel has been able to and you
know with Disney and everyone bring this
this world that exists in comic books so
faithfully to the screen and it's
continued and now with this sort of mash
up it can go anywhere and I think people
are just really really excited and they
it's infectious it's one of those things
that you do want to see huge and the
catharsis of seeing with a bunch of
people are going to be excited as you
are really look forward to it and I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun again
like I said it's we're in the same
position as all these fans we haven't
seen anything it's very exciting to be
to be a part of a history that I think
is gonna be around for a while and will
be remembered fondly and I think to be a
part of half of that time about I feel
really feel really lucky to still be
here and to still be written and to the
scripts and the stories I really love
getting to work on these movies I really
love working with the cast really love
getting work with the crew and I love my
character so it's it's been a thrill
I think they're really well-made films
and their app but they're really really
hard to make that's why we do have the
best camera department and the the best
writers and the best special effects
team we all try and ground these stories
and something real while enjoying the
time on screen we want it to be fun
you want it to be exciting we want to
challenge what viewers assume they're
gonna see and and and they innovate and
the Marvel Universe keeps keeps
switching things up on their audiences
and I think that's why people keep
coming back to see them they were
amazing it's not just the Russos it's
also the writers and it's also Kevin
Feige and it's also the studio who
really understand these characters and
their tracks and everybody has really
interesting character arcs and and I
wouldn't have wanted that job it's above
my pay grade
and that but it seems like they did an
amazing job I've only seen that 25
minutes that people have seen which was
truly amazing and I'm really looking
forward to seeing it well it's fantastic
you know like it's just like everything
is aligned and the Marvel has done a
really good job of weaving together a
tapestry of beautiful stories over ten
years with a multitude of diverse strong
bold characters just culminating right
before this with Black Panther and yeah
we just expect nothing but great success
and just a fun story for the for the
audience and for the fans it's been a
dream working with all the tremendous
actors and talent that I've always
looked up to for the most of my career
it was amazing to step on set and be
surrounded by that greatness
oh yeah especially to play a villain
I've always loved playing villains
they're the most interesting characters
in the lot you know I was a bit
overwhelmed I didn't expect this but
it's been amazing the fans out there are
so gracious and the cosplay yeah it's
beautiful
oh I am super excited oh my god I got to
see a bit of it during a tea during ADR
and Technology the special effects are
beyond anything I could imagine and a
lot of secrets we've been hiding secrets
for years on this movie this is a very
interesting night we finally get to
share it with people and then talk about
it but it's been hard because the past
several weeks we've been traveling the
world promoting the movie talking to
press and we but we haven't shown the
movie which is a very unusual thing so
finally tonight and within the next
couple days most of the world's going to
be able to see it so it's pretty amazing
[Music]
London Borough Tokyo Singapore Beijing
Shanghai La Soul yes and beyond to New
York and New York and DC left and we Joe
and I always end our tour in Cleveland
where we're from
yeah let's yeah it's great because I
mean these these movies are very
communal for us everyone that we work
with us like a family but we've done
four films been seven years we love all
the actors we love Marvel Disney so so
it's a great experience when we all get
to come together and share these movies
with such a rabid fan base that's really
why we make them is because we love
sharing them with the fans oh my gosh
well look they've never seen all of
their favorite characters interact and
that's I think what's special about this
movie also they've never seen a villain
like Thanos before and we're very
excited for audiences to experience them
ten years ago almost exactly ten years
ago we were right in the same spot
debuting Ironman one and I was extremely
excited because we finished it because
we actually delivered and made a movie
for the first time with Ironman one the
notion that in ten years we would be on
film number 19 having introduced so many
of the iconic characters beyond my
wildest dreams into the MCU and now
culminating in a film like infinity war
it's it's overwhelming and I and I
actually still can't believe it this
wouldn't have happened without those
fans the fans who lined up here in
Hollywood Boulevard on Saturday just so
they could see their stars walk down the
red carpet today who've been with us
through eight
team prior films who followed the
storyline and who know that we're
introducing a bad guy named Thanos who
has appeared a little bit in some of our
films but who from the comics is known
as a very very serious guy and what Josh
Brolin has done with that is frankly my
favorite part of the movie seeing all
the heroes together it's amazing but
what Josh Brolin has done with Thanos
which is the whole reason all of these
heroes have to try to band together is
incredible in 19 films in its in ten
years on it's a dream to me it's what is
so exciting is yes seeing these
characters interact with each other for
the first time seeing Thor with the
Guardian seeing Tony Stark with dr.
strange seeing spider-man with aliens I
mean it is it is so much fun but also
tapping into moments from all of our
prior films that we begin to pay off in
this and that we see it in this and most
importantly Thanos Thanos who for the
first time gets out of that [ __ ] he's
sat in a chair a lot in some of our
other movies he gets out of the chair in
this movie and he causes a lot of
problems and seeing our heroes who are
so powerful and who handle themselves
quite well in their own movies go up
against something they might not be able
to defeat is frankly to me what is most
exciting about
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you live together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
deny the prank you know
[Music]
[Applause]
but I'm looking at please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
and you went together here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
top rope
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the cast of
Avengers infinity war
[Music]
please help me welcome Joe and Anthony
Russo
[Applause]